this is a production of Cornell
University
so um thank you for the nice
introduction and the imitation so
actually I'm really excited to present
my work here at Cornell University so
when I was a graduate student Cornell
was my dream school so I could not
imagine I can you know present a talk at
Cornell University so I just I'm really
excited
so today I'm going to talk about some of
my recent research focusing on
Transportation silencing and we we you
know the what the other area in my lab
is working on biotic recognition so I'm
trying to connect these two uh together
so that's what I My Title Here is you
know transposing silency and how
transposal effect meiotic recognition
image
so I I took this figure from Citrix lab
you know this review actually helped you
10 since you should know transpose of
elements but what I want to summarize
that from the tenses the the major
conclusion is that you know transports
are really important so they are not
only junk DNA that you just try to
filter and then you know ignore them
they are really important they can you
know uh increase mutations they also can
uh regular gene expression so they are
involved in involved in many diseases so
Transporters are really important
and as you know that most of the most
trans persons you know the T are the
major components of many uh eukaryotic
species like the human genome nearly
half of your DNA are transposable
elements and then the mid genome over 85
percent of the DNA are transposable
elements
so you know although transportants are
the most abundant component in many
eukaryotic species most transportants
are stylus so that silenced by
epigenetic Pathways including like DMS
relation histone modification and the
non-coding rnas for example small
influence angles so if you pick up
transportation in a genome most of the
time you will find it is silence so it
is methylated or either mess or
vacillated or histor modified so they
can't move anymore
so that's what we find right now
so in plants if you work on Plants you
may know this only directed the
imagination pathway so um so you you can
see plants has two uh specific
polymerase called poor four four and
four five here so you can see purple on
the profile here so this powerful can
transcribe a DNA into a single strand
only so then this single strain RNA can
be copied into double stranded array by
rdr2 here dependent angry polymers too
so then this double stranded around a
can be cut into
um small angles you know and then load
it back to the original position or the
regions with similarities to trigger the
normal methylation so this is rddm
pathway
so this this rddm pathway can trigger
all of these three different types of
methylation in plants cgchg and chhh we
know that in mammals you may you may
have the major one is CG methylation
rate so in Plants we have pretty
abundant
cgchg and the chtg methylation so these
three different type of methylations
they are maintained by different muscle
transcripts so for example CG is
maintained by met1 and the chtg is
maintained by cme23 is a parameter
methyl transferase and the chhh in
heterochromic region is maintained by
cmp2 but all of this re can be triggered
by rddm
so if you take a look at the maze genome
you can see they are near 65 of the
cytosines are CH cytosins so which means
CH cytosines are really abundant however
if you check the methylation level so
you can see CG methylation level can up
to 84
chg methylation level can up to 72
percent but the CHC methylation globally
only 2.4 percent so it's very low
methylation level globally but you know
our lab is pretty interested in this
small level of imagination so little I
will show you why we are interested so
although chh methylation is genome
widely very low it can be enriched into
a high level near genes so you can see
here is a transcription study site here
the transcription termination site you
may notice that there are two peaks here
that we call chhh Islands you know you
can see that the methylation level of
the chhh can up to even 10 or 12 percent
and people also find that the major you
know cost causing inducing this chh
island are Transporters so you can see
you have a trans persons here you you
check the ages of the trans person you
will find that actually these ages of
Transportation are methylated which you
know form these islands so you can see
here the methylation level even up to 20
percent
and that's why people uh propose that
this island actually marked the
transition from
um
had to convert into genetic active view
chromatin so they they propose it's a
transition to you know separate how to
chromatin here and you committing here
to prevent you know kind of
um there are a lot of still arguments
you know one argument is that this
island is trying to prevent the
heterochromatic effects the other uh
argument is you know this island is
trying to protect the the gene
expression to uh flanking transportance
so we are pretty interested in
understanding you know how this Chism
isolation is initiated how it's
maintained to next Generations so that's
why we have been using a mutant called
mob1 image so mobile is amazed which is
the ortholog chain of rdr2 in adoptosis
so actually in this multiple mutant you
find uh you know 24 nucleus one they are
largely reduced so you can see this is a
Y pipe and then this is a mutant
and then you also can see at the chh
Island region methylation is largely
reduced so you can see right
so in addition to to using this mutant
we also use hybrid to test how
um silencing is initiated and maintained
so you know we you know for example you
have two different Amaze backgrounds or
different parents so they they are kind
of methylation is differentially
methylated so you can see at this region
parent one is highly methylated and the
parent 2 is imaginated so they are
separate rates but when you hybridize
them together these two sets of
chromosomes they are in the same nucleus
so how their methylation pattern look
like so we we propose three different
models for for example the first one the
methylation does not change so you can
see a little one inherits methylation
from parent one a little two inherits
methylation from parent no methylation
from parent two so then we call this no
change but there are many situations
these two chromosomes can interact with
each other so you can see this allele
two gains methylation although parent 2
does not have methylation at the same
Locus and this is we call Transformers
on methylation PCM and the other
situation is you know parent one has
methylation here but in the allele one
methylation is lost so we call this
transforms on demacylation
so when we have this these different
patterns of methylation or demacylation
we also want to to check whether this
kind of gain the methylation or remove
methylation can be maintained to next
Generations so that's why we also
um examine the F2 generation
so in order to do this you know we I um
hybridized the you know this mutant
heterozygous in the more 17 background
with the the mute the header like smoke
wine in the mosamic background so then
you can create a hybrid you know also
this is a mutant hybrid and then this is
a white hype hybrid so then you can
compare the combine the mutant effects
and the hybrid
so then later on We performed the whole
genome by sulfide sequencing of the two
parents and their F1 hybrids
so we we did how do you know by solve by
sequencing so here just shows you one
chromosome chromosome one means
chromosome one so this is a physical
distance and then this is a DM isolation
level so you can see that for CG and the
chtg methylation they are pretty stable
no and a large difference genome widely
but if you check the chhh methylation so
you can see these two other parents and
then this one is a Y type uh hybrid so
you can see actually hybridization
increase a lot of genome-wide chh
methylation
and the E1 so this is a mogwa hybrid so
we can see this mobile hybrid the cha
methylation level is still higher than
the two parents so this data suggests
that you know although this mutant we
know it can remove methylation so
actually the effects is is not as strong
as the hybridization so hybridization
even triggers more methylation than the
mutant the removal methylation
so you know this is a genome-wide
analysis so then later on we focus on
differentially methylated region we call
dmrs here you know we want to identify
the parental diamas so we can see this
uh this parent has higher methylation we
call this is a b sensory hyper DMR which
which means p73 has higher methylation
so then we want to see you know how this
parental drama
um you know located or how their pattern
looks like so if we identified over 7000
CG dmrs uh nice solid chddmr the CH even
up to 13 000 so these are between the
two parents
and if you check these two different
Amaze background lines you will find p73
has has more hyper CG and chgdmrs and
more 17 has more hyper chdms or this
also indicates these two uh maze lines
are pretty different and then this is
also consistent with the methylation
level you can see v73 has higher CG and
chg methylation and the most 17 has
higher chh methylation and we also check
the location of this parental DMS we
find that we also find that this chhdms
are different with CG and chdms so you
can see this hdmrs are largely located
in the 2kb upstream and downstream
region so which means this hdmrs are
near genes you know over
43 of this parental chhdms are in the
2kb upstream and 2kb downstream of genes
so then we want to check you know we
identified this parental diamas we want
to see how the immaculation level look
like in the hybrid when we combine these
two sets of chromosomes together so we
find that the majority parental diamas
they don't change their Mass alone even
you you you brought up these two sets of
chromosome together only 25 of of the
parental dmrs change them change their
methylone F1 so out of this 25 percent
um I think about 19 are TCM which means
they gain methylation after
hybridization there are also seven
percent uh you know tcdm which means
methylation is removed
um in those regions
and next we want to see you know we
observe this increased methylation at
some region and the decreased
methylation in some other region we want
to see which allele actually changed
methylation so that's why we compelled
High parents with low parent high allele
with lower allele so this here here high
power in the means the parent has higher
methylation so you can see here
you can see average this is apparent
this is F4 hybrid and then this is Mob
one you know hybridization at this TCM
actually induced a lot of methylation so
when you separate them into different
alleles we find that for CG and chg the
higher allele do not show significant
difference with High parents only the
low allele low parent allele uh it gains
methylation
for CG and the CH G methylation but if
you check chhh is different this chhh
actually boasts the high allele and the
low allele both of them gain the
methylation you know although the higher
allele is very high in the parent it
still gains more methylation of the
hybridization this also shows the chtm
isolation is different with CG and CHT
methylation as of the PCM pmrs for tcbm
you know methylation is removed this is
pretty consistent for these three
different methylation you can see all of
them high allele reduced
better for uh TCM gain macylation chh
you know both early or gain the
methylation
in our data
so we also check this one mutant effects
we find that these mutant actually many
uh functions on chh methylation so if
you can see in the mutant the change the
methylation you can see the TCM out of
this 1000 or 40 public 1043 PCM dmrs
more than 90 the methylation were
removed even you gain the methylation in
your F1 the methylation is removed by uh
mutant for CG and chg we identify only a
few of them uh change the methylation
after in the mutant background
background
so if you check the methylation level at
this affected PCM you'll find you know
cgchg they are reduced the methylation
in the mutants but the CH E chhh
methylation even removed to zero you can
see even lower than low parental allele
so this data you know suggests that or
at least indicates mobile mutation
largely works on chhh methylation
so as I showed you the the IDDM pathway
we know that small angle are the trigger
of of game isolation right so then we
want you know in F1 it can either gain
the methylation so where the small a are
produced or not so for example we
propose the two different models so you
can see parent one parent two parent one
has methylation so it has more always
produce and parallel two does not have
small a and then when we combine them
together
probably a little too you know produce
Morely although a parent one parent two
does not produce wine but after
hybridization it may produce only and
the other hypothesis is you know the
smaller are still produced from earlier
one and then trigger methylation in
trance you know small I don't have to
reproduce the game but the smaller from
parent one can trigger methylation of
allele 2 when you hybridize them
together to
um to to test these two different
hypotheses so we um perform the whole
genome small light sequencing from the
same tissue and we find that you know
consistent with previous statement
actually largely removed 24 nucleus one
ace and if you check the parents with F1
hybrids we don't observe very
significant change regarding smallness
are pretty similar
this is a genome-wide analysis then
later we compel the High parents with
low parents High parent means High uh
the parent with higher methylation so
typically if you have higher methylation
you have a higher you have more small
place we find high parent has
significantly more smallness than low
parents and if you compare the MPV value
MPV is the average level of small a
between of high pairing the low parents
if you can compel the MPV value with F1
hybrid if you text more like we don't
observe a significant increase morally
of course you know mob 1 removes a lot
of small and A's
and we also checked the ratios in
between the High parents and low parents
and between a higher Leo and the low
allele we also did not observe
significant difference so all of our
data suggests that small air are still
likely produced from the the original
allele you know that generates one a so
that and then trigger methylation
entrance so we we think our data
supports this hypothesis you know small
array are still produced from the
original allele and then trigger
methylation entrance
so next we want to see you know we we
have this gain of methylation we want to
see whether this methylation uh affects
gene expression so as I um explain it to
you you know this ch2 translation many
people find it uh promoter methylation
can suppress gene expression but in some
other research they also find the ch2
methylation is associated with higher
gene expression probably because of the
boundary we don't know
um which one is true so that's why we
propose the two different models the
first one is if chhh methylation is
associated with suppressed gene
expression and then you can see you have
this methylation in the promoter region
and then this this parent has produced
less transcripts compared to the other
allele a lot another parent has lower
methylation rate so after hybridization
this allele gains methylation so if chh
methylation suppress gene expression we
we should find that this racial uh
increase
it's hard for us to directly compel the
the expression level mainly because you
know in the F1 hybrids the two sets of
chromosomes are together we only can use
snip containing risk to this distinguish
the expression values so that's why we
use the ratio here so the other is if CH
methylation promotes gene expression we
may find that this ratio decrease
so then we based on these two different
models we try to find the energy you
imagine the first model or energy match
in the second model so we only find a 16
Gene show the first model and then 31
Gene you know shows the second model
which means that this 16 Gene actually
is 18 methylation suppress their gene
expression and then here this 31 Gene
you know CH immaculation May promote
their gene expression after gaining
methylation so then we are we were
pretty interested in comparing these two
sets of genes why they you know this 16
Gene was suppressed by uh ch3
methylation but this 31 genes were
promoted by Gene methylation
we compelled a lot of parameters and we
find actually this 31 Gene the second
group actually the gene lens is pretty
it's longer significant longer
for this 31 Gene and then uh gene
expression also higher and also Gene
body methylation this 31g is also higher
and we also find we also compiled
several histone modification
marks we find actually this 16 Gene is
suppressed as suppressed by ch3
methylation they have very high
h3k27 trimethylation so you know as you
know that this Market is a suppressive
mark right so you know for those genes
are suppressed by CST and isolation they
also have higher
um pistol marks so we are still not very
clear how these two G two set of genes
are different but at least we show they
are they have many features different in
including gene lensing expression Gene
body methylation and h3k27
trimethylation
so next we also wanted to ask you know
whether this triggered the methylation
can be maintained to next Generations so
that's why we we back crossed our F1 to
to uh one of the parents and then we
sequence the we sequence the whole
genome methylation level and then check
at those regions where methylation
gained the F1 how the methylation
pattern looks like in a bad cross bc1
individuals so we we also had a how
cgcheg data so here just shows the chhh
so our overall conclusion is that CG and
achg methylation are kind of
um overall good uh better maintained to
next Generations but the chhg
methylation uh even you gain the
methylation of the hybridization in the
Next Generation the methylation also
reduced so the maintenance is not very
stable
so this is overall data you know
different genotypes are very complicated
but overall we find the stage
immaculation
um it's not a better maintenance to next
Generations
so this is my part one I want to
summarize a little bit you know we find
hybridization increase the chh
methylation globally and we also find uh
at the TCM emrs you know gain the
methylation we find cgchg then okay
methylation is mainly caused by the
increased methylation for the of the low
parallel allele but for chh methylation
both high and low parental alleles are
increased in F1
we also found more plant you know works
on many chh methylation and we also find
a small rays are still produced from the
the allele that the original produced
small and the trigger methylation in
trance
and we also find stage methylation you
know it's both
is associated with both suppressed and
enhanced gene expression
we we found the newly triggered the
methylation can be maintained to Next
Generation but it varies in different
sequencing Cycles in context
so I become interested in biotic
recognition actually you know
starting working with them you know he
works on he works on transposable
elements so when I joined his lab I read
some papers and you know and most of
papers find the recommendation is
negatively collated with Transportation
density right so if you have a trans
person there normally this is not a hot
spot so typically you have a negative
correlation between recommendation and
transportance
so that's people also find in adoptysis
recognition rate is positively
correlated with Gene density positive
correlated which h3k4 trimethylation and
positively correlative it's no low
nucleus on density but negatively
correlative is DMS lesion
so so that's why you know if we we
remove methylation I want also want to
ask whether we can increase methylation
or not so the other thing we know during
transposition transportance uh create a
double stranded bricks right so you can
see this just the example of mutated
Transportation when it jumps out it
increase a double strand break
and we know that
um the first step for meiotic
recognition is produced substance bricks
so that's why at that time I want to ask
whether These Bricks generated by the
transposition of Transporters can be
used to to create more crossovers or not
so can this bricks be used here in the
meiosis Pathway to create more
crossovers so that's the main question
when I was a postdoc
um you know I want to check how active
and the silence transposal affect the
meiotic recognition so the first one is
either due to double strand brick when
they are active so for example if you
have a active Transportation here if you
have then you have a silence trans
person
when this trans person jumps out it
creates double strand bricks can this
bricks be used to uh to form more
crossovers or not
and then oh due to DM isolation they
bring two genes when they are epigenetic
silence as I showed you for those chh
islands there are many uh caused by
transporting insertions right if there's
a trans person there that transposal
needs to be silenced so then probably
when you have a hot spot so you can see
the gene is a hot spot and then when
there is a transpose and jumps need to
jump near to the Gene and then this
transposant got a massively get get
methylated so whether this
corresponds become you know code
response or not or you can change
another way if you have a
um if you have a cold spot if you remove
this transporter or remove the
methylation can you increase more
crossovers or not so these are the
central questions that when I was a
postdoc I want to you know understand
how active and silence trans person
affect meiotic recognition
so to test the first question uh to test
the how active transport transposer
affect multiple recognition we we have a
active mutated line in the image so
um we also have another silenced
population so in Demon's lab he has a
nuclear you know when this mu transposer
is active we can easily silence it by
adding this milk by introducing this
mutator into that line so then we have
an active Transportation population and
then we have a silence population
and then we can we for for genetically
they are identical because the the
insertion is in the active population
and also this insertion is is in the
silence population so then we can
examine the transport the recognition
around this active mu insertion and then
and compare the recognition around this
silenced Transportation so now we only
have one local stator so we we clone the
one Locus this meal we know where they
where it is so then we design a marker
and then examine the recommendation or
around this active mu and then this
silenced meal we find that this active
meal actually the Sandy Morgan came up
to 18 centimorgan the silenced meal only
travels anymore again so this at least
this Locus is as we expected to see you
know active Transportation when you have
an active Transportation there you have
a higher recognition rate
we my lab also you know trying to
um trying to clone all the meal
insertions and compel all the locations
how recognition differed between active
meal and silence meal
the other question is how do silence
transportation affect meiotic
recognition
so we you can do different two different
ways right you can try to induce an
insertion and then to see that hot spots
become colder spots or not or in other
in another way you can you know remove
that Transportation or remove the
silencing of that transport and to see
whether this gene or we can create a
more crossover hot spots or not so we I
use the the second one you know because
I have this mob one mutation I know it
can remove methylation near genes so
that that's why
when I was a postdoc I hypothesized that
in this mutant we may observe increased
methylation because this mutant can
remove or it can increase recombination
in the mutant because this mutant can
remove DMS lesion emsolation is kind of
suppressing uh recognition right so
that's the central hypothesis at that
time
but actually the data was even more um
interesting than we expected to see we
expect to see we we can observe more
crossovers but we find actually we only
observe more recognition in in the
chromosome arms so we can see these are
the 10 chromosomes chromosome 10 1 to 10
and then these are chromosome arms and
then this blue bus are parasite back
regions and then above zero means
increased methylation in the mutant and
below zero means decreased methylation
in the mutant so you can see out of the
10 chromosomes 9 chromosome increased
methylation
in in the chromosome arms in the mutant
and out of the 10 chromosomes all of
them were decreased uh recognition were
decreased
so if you do the static analysis they
are significant difference
so
next those are just a few markers so
then later on we developed more markers
across six entire six maze chromosomes
so you can see above zero means
increased methylation you can see almost
in the mutant the chromosome arms
recommendations are increased so you can
see here uh here and all the in the
parasite micro region uh recognition
were decreased this is pretty consistent
as our data
and also we did a cytogenetic analysis
using um each antibody of hei-10 you
know this Gene uh tracks the the uh
crossover precursor so this just shows
one um myocyte so this is a white type
and this is a mutant if you if you see a
red dot there that means one crossover
precursor one HDI 10 Focus So within a c
very big difference so overall here
probably 19 and here probably 20 we
didn't see very big difference
um
and also we later we chase the one
chromosome chromosome 6 we divided the
chromosome 6 into 10 equal beans and
then com you know calculates HDI 104 PSI
across many different myocytes so you
can see in being 10
in the mutant
the HDI 10 full size is largely
increased right so overall this data
suggests that the Crossovers are overall
unchanged but occurred more frequently
in the distal end of the chromosome if
the crossover events are just
redistributed in the mutant it's
increased in the pairs in the arms and
then decreased in a paracetic regions in
the mutants
so this is pretty similar as a research
in a you know similar as a matter one
mutant in abdomsis
so later we also want to understand you
know
um why this occurred so that's why we
sequence the
um
sequence the whole General DM
methylation of the mutant and the y-type
so normally you can see see methylation
you can see it's higher in the mutant in
the white type and compared to the
mutant rate cgchg do not show
significant difference between the
mutant and right type and then if you
check the the Island region near genes
you can see the mutant largely remove
this island and then if you check the
trans person you you also notice you
also can notice the ages of
Transportation methylation also reduced
so we think you know probably this more
permutation dramatically reduce
methylation near genes that result in
the
um redistribution of crossovers
so actually later on my lab also did a
high throughput the sequencing you know
we try to try to uh to create a high
resolution crossover map so that's why
we sequence the 90 back cross
individuals cogenome sequence and that
derived derived the form the mutant and
the over 100 derived from White type we
try to use all the Snips to to you know
to limited The Crossover at a very small
region so we just got the data
um we identified over you know 1100
crossovers from derived from Mob 1 and
then uh you know 1400 derived from the Y
type and then if you brought out this
crossover you can see many chromosomes
in the distal end for example chromosome
6. there are a lot of more crossovers in
the digital end in the mutant
but we are still not finished analyzing
the data we try to you know identify all
the Crossovers probably folks on the
Crossovers within 2kb and then to see
which region indeed uh crossover are
changed
we all we so for mobile we all all the
data I showed you right now are from
being used as female so we also did a uh
compel comparison between male and
female so if you if you see here above
one means methylation increase uh
recognition increase in the
um in the mutant so you can see overall
if you compare male and female they
don't have significant difference
however if you separate
um you know the chromosomes into
chromosome arm and parasite macro region
and compel the the white type and the
mutant you will find actually in the
mutant recognition called the larger
increase in the female and a larger
decrease in the in the parasite mag
region so this data is pretty
preliminary polymerate we are trying we
are still we also sequence the you know
almost another 100 or 200 Red Cross
individuals derived from the male we
want to compare female to male how their
regulation differed and we also want to
examine how DM isolation you know
of facts female and male differently
so actually from this data it inspired
me you know how either us let me ask how
you know methylation difference between
sexes in the Maize population so that's
why we I developed another project
trying to compel a recognition between
sexes
in the Maize population so you can see
the diversity of maize is amazing you
can see they are so large Diet
um diversities so then later on we used
uh the 25 name finder lines because they
are pretty diverged so it they can like
explain 85 percent of the main uh
population divert genetic diversity so
that's why we use these 25 name lines
and then we want to compel female male
meiosis so that's why we you know cross
these 25 name lines with bsm3 and then
we created this F1 hybrids so then we
use this F1 hybrids as female and
meanwhile uses one this F1 hybrid as
male to produce fat cross populations so
then this these two different background
populations can use it to estimate
recognition occurred in F1
so that
so until now we we did a original
genome typing by sequencing we found the
data is really interesting until now we
screen the nine lines and out of this
nine lines we found three of them have
higher male meiosis so you can see b97
Ohio 43 and I il-40h this is a sweet
corn and this is a temporary maze so
these three lines have a higher uh male
recognition and the other five lines do
not show significant difference
and the uh the last line called the CML
103 it has higher female meiosis
so this data is pretty interesting to us
you know I um we we thought
probably some lines are different some
lines are not different but uh overall
out of this nine we identify the street
have a higher uh male meiosis
so if you check the recognition
um
race or genetic distance you can see it
varies although b97 has higher male
recognition also it will varies in
different chromosomes you can see
chromosome 7 chromosome a is chromosome
9 they are very more different very
little difference but other chromosomes
are very big difference and also you can
notice that in the distal end
recognition is kind of very higher or
recognition read is higher in the in the
mail so you can see chromosome
chromosome 2 chromosome 4
um or six they are all you know overall
recommendation is higher in b97 hybrids
and especially in the distal end in the
the terramere region
many chromosomes they have very high
recognition in email
so if you check CML 103 this one has
higher female meiosis
recognition rate typically if you you
can see here when it has a higher female
it's not only limited to the distal end
it across the entire chromosome you can
see even not near the distal end
so this data also shows us the
difference right normally if you have a
higher male
um recognition rate either they are
limited to the the terramina region or
distal ends but when this line has a
higher female recommendation it comes
off across all over the chromosome not
only limited to several regions so these
are really not preliminary but we we
still haven't finished and analyzing the
data
so then next we compile the female you
know all the recommendations across
different lines across female and across
male so the data is very interesting to
us we find that you know recognition
female recognition is kind of very
stable so you can see this female we
don't observe very large difference even
across different lines so they are
pretty stable but it very substantially
during male meiosis so you can see this
male different lines being nice b97 is
very high and the CML 103 is very low
but but the female is very stable so
overall this data suggests that meiosis
recognition differs largely in different
maze backgrounds and also this data
tells us metric recognition is generally
very stable during female meiosis but a
very varies largely during male meiosis
so we are not finished analyzing the
data we are also screening all the uh
remaining of public over 10 lines so
after we screening we try to identify
which line has very large difference
between male and a female and then the
other one maybe has very high uh male
you know then we can send these two
representative lines for whole genome
resequencing and then we can create a
very high crossover
um
resolution crossover maps to identify
which region actually I change are
different between female and male
so we we try to build this high
resolution crossover Maps we are trying
also trying to isolate myocytes to do
transcriptal analysis one analysis PM
isolation analysis and histone
modification analysis we try to
integrate all of the data together to
tell how you know sex is the
recommendations are differs between
sexes in Maize
so I want to summarize my second part we
find one active mutated insertion at the
uh you know increased recognition
we also find that mobile actually
decreased methylation in Paris and Mac
region but the increased methylation in
uh recognition in chromosome arms we
also find public crossover
redistributing is likely driven by rules
of chh methylation near genes
and we we find the DM isolation maybe uh
you know different play different roles
between male and female recommendation
and we also find the melotic recognition
differs substantially between sexes in
different genetic backgrounds we also
find the multi-core connection is
generally stable during female meiosis
but very substantially during male
meiosis in different genetic backgrounds
so I would like to uh thank my postal
advisor you know Dr Damon Lynch I
started I I initiated this project in
his lab and then he finally let me take
this project to my own lab so that's why
we we we finally have a big project so
also I want to thank Professor Rachel
wine you know she did all the
cytogenetic work for for our lab we are
a pure competition not a pure we we did
a lot we do a lot of computational stuff
um and I also want to thank voltag you
know he reviewed my papers reviewed my
background uh proposals which make my my
lab survived otherwise I may not have
people working for me
I also want to thank all the
undergraduates and graduate students you
know they did all of the work so my
research is funded by uh NIH with and
unlessf and also the startup from my
previous University and Miami University
and my current University nursing
Florida so with that I would like to
take any questions if you have
yeah
wonderful talk um I had a question why
do you think chhh methylation was
increased in the hybrid even with the
mop one mutation
yeah so we we actually work on several
different projects we find actually CHS
translation is very dynamic
so for CG and the CG methylation they
are kind of very stable even you have
stress they may not change too much but
for chh they are very stable so that's
what that's they're the CH is very
Dynamic so that's why I hypothesize that
chh is kind of like a buffer you know
there are so many cytocines across
across the genome although they are very
low level but there are so many so they
can be so as a barber you know when
suggest suggests come to the plants and
then they change but they can rapidly
return to the normal level after the
stress is released that's just my
hypothesis but we have another project
in my lab we inoculate the the plants
with passengers we also observe the chin
methylation reduced not the increase in
that experiment but all CG and chtg
they're globally not changing too much
of course you can identify a lot of
differential methylated region but you
know why you don't see much difference
after inoculation but you observed you
know why the decrease of chin
methylation so and also another lab they
did a heat stress they also find the chh
methylation change the rapidly so what
we hypothesize that this chhh is kind of
like a buffer you know try to buffer the
changes of the chromosome to maintain
the chromosome for example
um
stability that's just a hypothesis but I
I yeah I we observed the ch3 methylation
changed dynamically in response to
different
stresses for example or hybridization
yeah
thank you
I was wondering um for the first part of
your talk uh did you break down the
transmethylation patterns by te family
or sub family and notice any like Trends
based on the specific
like chhh sites that you were profiling
so you mean those uh TCM pmas yeah F1
yeah we checked the different types of
transportants
um when you see a the majority are DNA
type transportants at the TCM DMS so we
have the data they are in the
supplemental we submitted this paper we
did we checked all different kinds of
Transporters the the majority wise PIR
Transporters and then next is halitron
and then next is LTR retrain transport
and near the
overlapping with chh like all the
different families like behave the same
though in terms of like changes in
methylation pattern over their family
specific if we didn't do family level
yeah we did only PIR
um DNA trans person and the LTR retrain
Channel
I think we didn't do family specific
level yeah that's maybe a good point to
see other if there is any specific
transportance there cool thanks for a
great talk too
thank you actually I want to continue
with the last question how is when you
increase the chh methylation we'll kind
of specific tea family are kind of
triggered they do calculate all the P
insertion transposition to know which
kind of family are associated with cjh
methylation so yeah
that's a good question you know we when
we work on Transporters we based on The
annotation
so I I think that there are some
things we can't do using our current
data
because we
folks or we rely on The annotation there
may be some lonely families you know we
don't know so that's why we finally
didn't do too much analysis on
Transporters we initially we plan to do
transportants and finally we find that
we have very you know low power to to do
every family or
um
polymorphisms between uh more 17 and b73
mainly because we when we use the more
17 genome we use a snip replacement
genome that which means we we are gonna
work focusing on the polymorphic
transporters
if you want to use a de Noble uh more 17
genome it's just a little bit of
computational challenging to identify
which from which transposing its present
absence so and then you we also want to
tell different alleles so then finally
we decided to use a snip replace the
genome we lost all the transposal
polymorphism data that's the that's the
weakness I didn't want to point out
because I don't want the reviews to ask
this question but we know yeah we'll
lose lost a lot of data regarding trans
persons because we use a snip replace
the genome so that's why I finally
decided to switch my focus from
transportance to dmslation
my initial thought was trying to you
know compel this has a transposing
insertion this one does not have whether
how the methylation changed in F1 but
finally we didn't get there
um probably in the future we can do that
just the transposer you know they are
repeats if you want to
you if you want to and finally actually
essentially we work on perimutation many
of you know that right we compel the
same Locus both of them are in the
parents and in the F1 hybrids we lost
all the transports and polymorphism data
using our computational approach yeah so
that's why I kind of do a lot regarding
which type of or which tea family
because all the annotations are based on
b73 yeah
and thank you and also one more small
question from my own interest is that I
also curious about how you can
correlation the transposal waves
recombination events so how you ident
screen for this recommendation event is
you are using like molecular macro like
Snips to tracking down the location and
frequent so yeah we use black horse
populations you know we I indeed I have
a the light
so see we we have you can see your house
polymorphic markers between these two
backgrounds and then in the F1 hybrid
there is when this recognition occur
between here so you have four different
gametes and then these two are the
preventable gametes and then these two
are the recombinant gametes if you back
cross you will identify this kind of
recombinance
using the markers here so that's why my
lab we use that cross population to
examine recognition already occurred in
F1
yeah unlike a Vortex lab they can
directly work on my own size then you
know but
we we are not good at it that so that's
why we use black cross populations to
estimate the recognition already
occurred here
thank you
hi very cool
um so thinking about the stuff you
talked about at the end with the um male
female differences in uh recombination
um are there any differences in the
um inheritance of uh the small rnas that
are maybe responsible for targeting DNA
methylation and with that perhaps
explain what's going on with
recombination rates in and developing
you know of yours that's possible so
that's why we are going to do you know
we are trying to
to sequence a lot of small arrays or DM
isolation
but there's a problem here I know
probably what heck knows that you know
isolating female myocytes is really
challenging so we counter directly get
the smaller data or DM isolation make DM
isolation data directly for female
myocytes so we only have this data for
male myocytes so we kind of we don't
have compel but I propose that you know
um I think you you can see here
[Music]
um
for female and a male we observe
difference I think probably Quantum
structure is really important between
female and male because their their DNA
is same right so I think that their
content structure in the female and
common structure in the middle is very
different
but we are going to probably for my next
30 Years I want to find out find out
whether it is true or not yeah
uh you already answered the question
what you want to ask but I have the
second one
um
what do you think why they be in 97 have
the increased number of the crossover do
you have any ideas how it happened and
why it happened we don't know
we don't have any idea so
um
you can see they are pretty mixed I feel
I previously saw the probably some
tropical mates they are very large
difference and the temporary mates they
are very large different but it looks
like you can see they say tropical Maze
and then this one is also tropical Maze
and then at the b97 I think it's
temporary the maze so we don't know why
they show difference but you also have
b73 and on those those are hybrids yeah
but I think this data is more
interesting we find the female is pretty
stable you can see we already screen the
nylons female no big difference no
significant difference only male changed
yeah because what we what we found was
that reduce of the CG and CG methylation
increase the crossover frequency that
might be something what you can look
that's mean look on the methylation
status of all of the zimbers yeah
for DM isolation sequencing and then we
can compare b97 with all the other lines
yeah let's we we are planning to do
thank you
we are still screening the remaining
lines but I I we already screened at
night we find the female is stable I
think this is probably the general
pattern and the male is very diverged
great talk this is on yeah okay
um I was actually gonna ask about this
so it's perfect that you're on this um I
noticed that I can barely read it from
back here but k11 or kl11 that kind of
behaves like a male do you have any
ideas of how you might be able to use I
mean ki11 uh
on the other side on the so yeah you'll
have the female side yeah it kind of
behaves like a male where it has that
longer distribution and then there's
other ones on the male side that have a
very short distribution
um do you think that you can kind of use
these as a way to figure out why there's
such a tight distribution in the females
in such a wide distribution in the males
like what's driving it or are these like
standing out as a special thing and the
same thing I think was true for do you
have a hypothesis for why the meiotic
recombination rates from the female
parental side are so wide over the
chromosome but in the male side are so
tight to the end
I even do notice that so
um so you know our data is pretty we
don't have enough data so we are still
working on that so we as I mentioned we
when after we screen all the 25 lines we
will send for high school product
frequency so then we can identify
crossover at a high resolution so then
we can compare all the DNA sequences or
DM isolation data so when we have all of
these different types of data I think we
may have a better idea you know why
female is so stable and a male virus and
what kind of parameters is the most
important
yeah we we don't know how too many
much idea right now yeah thank you for
your question thank you for pointing
this out
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu